over the last five years there's been an
intense focus on a really really scaling
and rebuilding and Reap lat forming the
eBay marketplace and expanding into many
new markets and new countries when I
arrived you know one of the big
opportunities and charters was oK we've
built the foundation now the next move
for eBay is building an engaging
experience I want people sitting around
my table and my staff talking to me
about the science of cart and check-out
I want people talking to me about the
science of search in browse at eBay I
want to be talking about personalization
and I want to be talking about product
discovery and engagement we sell more
new and let's call it fixed price items
than the traditional auction business
that the company was founded on so is it
fair to say that you feel the eBay could
be a first choice over Amazon in
people's hearts and minds
well you know I want to be realistic
about that our product mix at the moment
is not focused on replenishable x' the
way to think of it is the sellers on
eBay today are really interesting
ranging from the individual to the small
business to the art collector the record
shop all the way up to now mass
retailers right and we are getting big
brand names as well that are very
interested in stepping on to the ebay
platforming and bringing out you know
interesting collections of their
inventory my job as a chief product
officer is how do we simplify the
shopping experience I mean 145 million
users and growing 650 million items ha
and coming from this broad spectrum of
sellers how do you make that rational
sensible and delightful so that people
get it and they come back often so we're
absolutely you know building towards
highly engaging repeat customer
experience on eBay and you know and
don't forget Mobile at over 20 billion
dollars a year in merchandise sold
through just through the mobile platform
on eBay and it is massive and it's
absolutely
growth engine going forward when you
think about you know future of shopping
it this is it you know it's with you
24/7 it's with you it's your alarm when
you wake up in the morning it's with you
on the train ride when you get out of
here to go home tonight and that's when
people have their attention units
available and focused on shopping and so
I'm obsessed over the multi-screen
shopping experience and looking at how
we can build and change the game in
commerce across devices